we've got big breaking news I got this
clip just popped it up on Twitter
January 6 video from Tucker Carlson
shows the police assisting the Q Shaman
as he walks around the Capitol Building
no joke let's play the video they helped
him they acted as his tour guides oh
here's video of chansley in the Senate
chamber Capitol police officers take him
to multiple entrances and even try to
open locked doors for him we counted at
least nine officers who were within
touching distance of unarmed Jacob
chansley not one of them even tried to
slow him down
chancelly understood that Capitol Police
were his allies video shows him giving
thanks for them in a prayer on the floor
of the Senate watch
contrast the reality of what Jacob
chansley did in the Capitol building on
January 6th the India and there it is
right there I mean Tucker is Hansley
they helped obviously got way more to
add to this but there's the video right
there the police escorting him through
the building and finding an open
entrance to get him in
to get him into the chambers
I don't think that's considered
entrapment because he was already on the
premises not when the police are on
camera Fanning people in and opening the
outside doors to let people so we see
corroborative evidence that they let
other people into the building and then
competitive evidence sure that they
toured what's his name again I want to
call him
Jason chanceley is that what it is
chancellor is that what he said let's
play um yeah acted as his tour guides
and Kim chansley they helped him Jacob
they acted as his tour guides here's
video of chansley in the Senate chamber
Capitol police officers take him to
multiple entrances and even try to open
lock doors for him that's amazing Jake
Angeli born Jacob Anthony Angeli
chansley uh the police escorted him
through the building I think that's
absolutely exonerates this guy he was he
was being led around by cops I mean and
this is why the Democrats would not
release the footage and this is why I
have been saying Ian the Democrats are
evil I don't even I don't want to put on
a political party there are very evil
people doing things right now I don't
want to mask it with a political party
because there's a lot of good Democrats
too I will name Democrats or even name
one name a good Democrat my mom I think
no I'm talking about the political
officers I'm talking about the
politicians who are sitting on the j6
committee who are withholding evidence
that would exonerate a man who he's been
locked up ever since hasn't he
so name name for me a good sitting
Democrat Bernie Sanders he's not a
Democrat he's independent
and besides he came out in favor of War
yeah but Bernie he's a good guy
um nobody's perfect I mean I can
scarcely name a an honest Republican are
you sure I didn't know Bernie was
independent sorry about that Thomas
Massey
yep he's a Democrat man no no
Republicans I could give maybe rokana a
a nod I don't know a lot of them though
I don't know I don't know many of them
at all aoc's being implicated in uh
ethics investigation because she got all
this free stuff Conde Nast paid for her
her uh her limo or whatever her ride to
the Met Gala she that that's look we had
Matt Gates come into the studio and
we've got a fine selection of bourbon
and I said uh Congressman Gates please
help yourself to anything you might
partake a drink you may partake and uh
he said that's too expensive I can't
accept that for the for the Pappy stuff
and I was a bottom shelf five dollar
garbage if he wants to have some whiskey
it's got to be under a certain price and
I was like oh no no yeah whatever I
don't I don't know do just make sure you
do it right he's like yeah no problem
AOC received hundreds if not thousands
of dollars these people I'm sorry they
are evil anything January sorry the
January 6th committee was sitting on
evidence that would exonerate this man
and they lied about it that it's more
power and Raskin
lied about me
when he played a video and and this was
a big mistake on the part of the
Democrats because it red pilled a lot of
yeah including my mother exactly because
I was reading a Fox News article where
Trump says we're going to protest it's
going to be wild and it's like Fox news
reporting Donald Trump says it's going
to be wild I was like well you know it
might be because Trump supporters are
really angry he plays it out of context
and then what I'm hearing from my
friends is like what you just said
people being like what
Tim Poole's not calling for anything now
that's crazy these people are evil yeah
they definitely put things out of
context to purposely ruin lives and they
did the same thing the media did it with
me when I worked at the Daily Caller I
was in a video with Ajit Pai who's the
head of the FCC at the time and they
were like repealing net neutrality
and I was just in a video like in the
background dancing along to some silly
meme video that they were making with
him and the media left leftist media
wanted to destroy him because this net
neutrality thing which I still don't
even understand what was going on with
it
but they pinpointed me and said hmm
what's what's her deal and they found
like a silly YouTube video that I made
about like pizzagate but it was really
just like me talking about my experience
on the Deep Web and like knowing that
this cheese pizza code actually is a
real code I did not talk about common
ping pong I did not talk about anything
that was like
bad about this conspiracy theory thing
but they went around Joy read on MSNBC
mentioned me by name every single outlet
was mentioning me and lying flat out
lying saying that I promoted highly
promoted the Comet Ping Pong conspiracy
theory which I never did just because
you knew that CP meant was always
they knew that no one would actually
look at my video they knew that no one
would do that they just read the article
and then I was getting a bunch of
messages and everybody hating me and it
was just like now my reputation is I'm a
piece of Gator when I'm like I never did
that I think I never promoted this like
conspiracy theory I was just talking
about the Deep Web the cheese pizza is
actually not even that deep that's just
on that's on 4chan on on the B board
people have been arrested for putting
cheese pizza code out there for actual
travel there's a rest you can look up
articles about it but they they don't
care they lie they did it on purpose and
it what did it do they wanted to ruin
Ajit Pai for this you know political
reason but really it ruins this girl's
me reputation for what that's all they
they care about they don't care about me
as a person or good doing good the
Democrats only have one thing to
campaign on Donald Trump is a Nazi yes
and so with January 6th I I believe
there is a strong probability that they
did want this to happen
Trump claims he wanted more security and
Pelosi didn't get it look man I've said
it before if on I think it was what May
29th 2020 the the Insurrection at the
White House if Trump ordered the police
to stand down he would be president
right now
because these these people the Democrats
they understand politics they understand
public perception if the far left ripped
down the fencing at the White House
stormed into the building and set fire
to it and started doing a whole bunch of
them because they burned a guard post
and a church I assume they said fire to
the White House and Trump went to the
bunker
he would come out the next day and say
the far left extremists have been waging
a war on this country for months and
something needs to be done about it I am
calling on the governors of these states
and the mayor of D.C to take the action
acquired
instead
the police came in made the arrests
fired tear gas cleared people out and
the media came out and said Donald Trump
is a fascist which is so crazy because
if he had cracked down and called on
people to start cracking down that would
be like what Phil was talking about
earlier the fascist response to the
Communist uh meddling and he doesn't
have that fascist bone in his body he's
not that kind of guy he's like a a
liberal businessman he's not instead we
get the inverse on January 6th where
when a bunch of people show up some guy
for some reason keeps telling everybody
to go in the building and they keep
calling him a Fed he then Whispers In
some guy's ear who tears a barricade
down and then when the bumbling goddards
show up the cops fan them in open the
doors and give guided tours the
Democrats withhold the evidence and
claim it was an Insurrection for months
to to years now to yeah going on years
and they're going to try and use that
fortunately with Republicans squeaking
by a tiny Victory this stuff comes out
and Tucker Carlson is able to
definitively prove Democrats lied about
it all I will say it again proof Beyond
A Reasonable Doubt presented by Tucker
Carlson reposted by us about half an
hour later the police giving a guided
tour and even opening the doors for the
Q Shaman completely exonerating him and
proving Democrats lied about completely
everything do you think it's going to
make a difference
well the challenge is when it comes to
his criminal case
if this was being tried in say like a
state jurisdiction thing and this
evidence was withheld by the federal
government it probably would exonerate
them but the fact that it is the federal
government withholding the evidence and
Prosecuting him I don't think he's going
to get anything but why was it withheld
why was that not made available
because they're evil Ian so I mean but
legally how is it why was it withheld
they just don't have to show their own
evidence they said the American
public
section please that doesn't sound legal
they they are the ones who are sitting
on the footage and they say for security
reasons we won't give it out was it 14
000 hours of such a sham 44.
everything they can to portray a certain
agenda that's all they care about like
not good I think realistically that they
will be satisfied with this process
being the punishment for these people
being led around and let into the
building
um beyond that I'm not sure how someone
could sleep at night thinking this guy
was led around exactly here's here's
what I'll do if uh if I were to ever
become president I would run on the
campaign of criminally charging the
members of the January 6 committee for
withholding evidence that left and that
left innocent people in jail
and this is all
they don't want Trump to be president
so they would rather throw innocent
people young people that have their
whole lives ahead of them under the bus
just to make Trump look bad
yeah there are there are there are bad
people there are people on January 6 who
are fighting that's bad those people
should be judged but when you've got
evidence being withheld as to what
really happened by democrats and then
lying like Adam Schiff lying about Trump
and Russia get at a certain point
there's got to be some kind of like use
of public office for the purpose of
defrauding the American people as a
criminal charge or something
I mean I have hope that there's that
there's possible charges that can be
filed I hope that there's lawsuits that
can be filed by uh private individuals
I'm hoping that we still have a judicial
system that works uh I know that it it
does to at least some extent right
because if not
Kyle Rittenhouse wouldn't be free if it
was completely and totally you know
thrown away thanks for watching this
clip from the timcast IRL podcast hang
out with us live Monday through Friday
at 8 pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time